this video is brought to you by
Skillshare hi welcome to another
ColdFusion video the year was 1969 the
Beatles had just recorded their final
album together Abbey Road the early
internet ARPANET was being built in a
Stanford classroom and new Armstrong had
just added those famous words we had
just landed a person on the moon and
soon children everywhere began dreaming
about how when they grew up they too
would go to the moon it was a wondrous
time filled with optimism except the
technology didn't evolve those dreams
never amounted to reality instead of
growing a whole industry around space
humans barely made it back to the moon
only 12 people have ever visited the
extra-terrestrial surface but just like
the United States and the Soviets were
locked in a space race in the 1960s
today 50 years on we're starting to see
a different kind of space race NASA is
firing up its rockets once again to go
back to the moon and a multitude of
small startups and industries have
sprung up around this renewed interest
in space Elon Musk Richard Branson and
Jeff Bezos are all racing to see who
will conquer the new space industry in
this episode let's take a look at the
new space race competing so why has
there been such researching interest in
space and the movie will put simply the
economics are starting to make sense now
new industries are already forming
around space for example 3d printing
human organs has become much simpler
without the need for scaffold structures
thanks to zero gravity also the
manufacturing of more energy-efficient
fiber-optic cables also becomes possible
in space space manufacturing could
create many more enabling technologies
which could lead to industries that
don't even exist you will explore these
later in the video but going to space
and the moon is more than just a better
way to make products
extraterrestrial colonization is
becoming a popular idea and space
tourism has become a fascination of
billionaires and dreamers alike
[Music]
the Artemis lunar program is NASA's
attempt to return to the moon companies
like SpaceX and Blue Origin are
competing to provide their services of
commercial lunar payloads the mission
for NASA's Artemis program is to quote
land the first woman and next man on the
moon the program intends land on a never
before visited part of the moon the
South Pole by 2024 the mission would
give astronauts 6.5 days on the lunar
surface more than double the longest
duration of the previous lunar mission
NASA also plans to make good use of time
on the moon by setting up equipment
before the astronauts reached the
surface and engineering a summon feature
on their Rovers so they can self drive
to the landing site of the astronauts
according to NASA this is the first step
in sending humans to Mars
using what they learned during this
lunar program there is hope for a future
Mars program to begin and in their own
words the next era of exploration I am
the first NASA Administrator that was
not alive when we had people on the moon
I was born in 1975 our last mission was
in 1972 I don't have that memory
we cannot let another generation go by
where we don't have that memory we need
to get to the moon this is the Artemus
generation we need to own it we need to
take control of it and we need to make
it happen as NASA turns to private
companies to help them reach the moon
the world's richest man jumped at the
opportunity Jeff Bezos Blue Origin has
recently partnered with Lockheed Martin
North Grumman and Draper to build a
vehicle which will deliver and return
payloads including astronauts to and
from the moon's surface
more recently Blue Origin has showcased
their lunar lander it was called a blue
moon they hope that this will be used in
the 2020 for NASA lunar missions Bezos
wants blue origin to help establish a
lunar base and provide NASA with a cargo
carrier service support to and from the
moon blue origins vehicles are expected
to carry 3.6 metric tons of goods as he
explained it takes 24 times less energy
to take off from the moon than Earth
Jeff Bezos is investing around 1 billion
dollars a year into Blue Origin
anticipating if the logistics of space
could prove to be very lucrative it's
time to go back to the moon this time to
stay and it's this generations job to
build that road to space so that the
future generations can unleash their
creativity when that is possible when
the infrastructure is in place just as
it was for me in 1994 to start Amazon
when we have that infrastructure in
place for the future space entrepreneurs
you will see amazing things happen
and it will happen fast I guarantee it
people are so creative once they're
unleashed but the heat is on and Blue
Origin isn't the only one trying to win
these contracts
[Music]
spacex along with several other
companies have been selected to be part
of nasa's program however acceptance by
nasa doesn't guarantee any of these
companies contracts rather NASA is
building their lunar program to have a
pool of companies capable of delivering
a payload to the moon effectively it's a
special Club of possible contract
winners for each time NASA needs a
payload sent in the future companies
like Blue Origin and SpaceX will go
head-to-head in building their best
vehicle for NASA's needs Blue Origin
might have a strong competitor to face
20 get the public real fired up I think
we gotta we gotta have a base on the
moon you know like average pretty cool
and then going beyond that getting
people to Mars yeah you know having some
commander presence on another heavenly
body that's the continuance of the dream
of Apollo that like if all really
looking for Elon Musk was perhaps one of
the first pioneers of this new space
industry when he founded SpaceX in 2002
right now SpaceX has big plans for the
future colonization of Mars however in
the meantime the company is also
providing satellite launching space
tourism and as mentioned has recently
joined forces with NASA for their moon
missions firstly let's look at
satellites where SpaceX has a big
interest this StarLink project is an
ambitious effort for SpaceX to launch in
a network of small satellites into space
to provide a global reliable and fast
internet service
the satellite launching industry
comprises 77% of the 360 billion-dollar
space industry as a whole so it is core
to the future of the entire space
industry
[Music]
roughly speaking Elon Musk is literally
building his own Internet and recently
he showcased the technology in the most
Elon Musk way possible by sending a
tweet using a styling satellite coverage
of the star link system is expected to
be available in the United States and
Canada from 2020 with nearly global
coverage to follow a year later it's an
ambitious expansion effort but not
everyone is happy with the project
astronomers have recently been
complaining that their views are being
obstructed by styling satellites
currently the company has launched about
a hundred and twenty-two of a possible
42,000 satellites meaning that this
interference with astronomical studies
may become far greater in the future in
the field of the space Internet SpaceX
has some competitors with Amazon trying
to launch their satellite internet in
the form of project Cooper while another
company oneweb is attempting to do the
same but in saying this SpaceX appears
to be in the driver's seat having the
capabilities to launch and is indeed
already implementing their styling
project in the grand scheme of things
providing a global Internet service
could be a big financial payoff while at
the same time could improve the lives of
many people who traditionally have been
disadvantaged with poor or no internet
coverage in their part of the world
remember access to the Internet brings
all the world's collective knowledge
with it
[Music]
another area for SpaceX is space tourism
in a previous video I did cover space
access dear moon project and it's a
pretty interesting concept it's
basically a moon flyby that would last
six days and has proposed to launch in
2023 Japanese billionaire yuusaku mae
zawa partially funded the project and
has dubbed the flight an art project but
he plans to bring along half a dozen
artists with him on the trip and he
hopes that this trip would inspire
artists to promote world peace but yet
for space tourism this yet another
player who wants a piece of the pie his
name is Richard Branson we have nearly
800 astronauts who signed up wanting to
go up next year we'll start taking
people to space the resources and the
money that we make from that we will be
putting to things like point-to-point
trouble with that will be expanded and
one day do point-to-point travel we've
got another spaceship company called
virgin orbit which will be putting
satellites into orbit later this year
doing things a little different than his
counterparts Richard Branson is not
planning to launch from Earth Virgin
orbit funded by a 1 billion dollar
investment from sister company Virgin
Galactic is planning to launch its first
rockets which will deliver small
satellites into orbit by early 2020 but
instead of launching from the ground
like SpaceX and Blue Origin virgin orbit
plans to do it with a little help
they're going to strap their rocket to
the wing of a Boeing 747
the plan is to launch midair increasing
reliability and reducing cost sister
company Virgin Galactic having recently
debuted as the first and only publicly
traded space company with their IPO on
the new york stock exchange is focusing
on space tourism with similar launch
mechanisms they followed by unveiling
their new Under Armour space suit for
suborbital flight Virgin Galactic has
also started its astronaut readiness
program the program will provide
nutrition and fitness for some of the
world's first space tourists
despite this space tourism isn't
available to the masses just yet a 90
minute suborbital flight on Virgin
Galactic spaceship 2 will set you back
$250,000
but that's not to say that Virgin
Galactic doesn't have customers 600
people have already signed up to fly the
company is looking to launch flights in
Blue Origin is also setting its sights
on the tourist market planning to give
customers ten minutes at the edge of
space in the newly tested and developed
new Shepard rockets
along with the Giants that a SpaceX Blue
Origin and Virgin Galactic this emerging
industry dubbed new space has given rise
to many smaller startups made in space
is a space manufacturing startup from
Silicon Valley funded by a 20 million
dollar investment from NASA this company
is pioneering 3d printing in space and
even has their own 3d printer on the
international space station the charging
agencies are fee to 3d print new tools
as required by astronauts a company
called space Pharma has sent its
unmanned mini laboratory to the
International Space Station where it's
conducting experiments in microgravity
another startup called Planet Labs is
using as 200 small satellites to take
approximately 1.4 million images of the
earth each day they're using this data
to help monitor and improve agriculture
on earth and that's just naming some of
the few companies doling into this new
and exciting industry so knowing that
this is a YouTube video there's
naturally going to be cynical
reductionists and they're probably
thinking what's the point of all of this
this is just such a waste of money that
could be spent better elsewhere why even
go to space in the first place well I've
mentioned this in the previous video and
it's worth highlighting again
technologies that are developed in yeast
and space travel could benefit all of us
in the long run many things that you use
every day have come to be thanks to NASA
pushing the boundaries here are some
examples
[Music]
digital image sensors were developed by
a NASA scientist his task was to
engineer a miniature camera for missions
the CMOS or complementary
metal-oxide-semiconductor is a type of
image sensor that's widely used in
smartphones and countless other mini
cameras like GoPros enrich baby food is
another NASA pioneered invention through
an attempt to create a recycling agent
for long term space flights research was
carried out into microalgae in bread
mold the scientists were part of the
program spun this off to create baby
formulas and today around 90 percent of
baby formula contains the substance
based off microalgae lasik technology
originated in the 1980s from NASA's
attempts to use lasers to track the
docking of space vehicles eventually
this technology would fall into the
hands of optometrists LASIK allows
people to forego traditional glasses and
regain their quality of sight and this
is by no means all the list keeps going
thermal blankets memory foam portable
cordless vacuums freeze trying NASA have
invented or helped to pioneer in some
capacity
thousands of technologies in fact NASA's
technology transfer program ensures that
the research and development completed
and NASA is passed on to the public to
maximize the benefit of the nation they
even release an annual magazine called
spin-off featuring some of the newest
technology made available to the public
and it's fair to say most or even all of
this wouldn't exist without scientists
and engineers pushing the boundaries
because of the tough demands of space
travel
same conclusion we are living in very
interesting times there's one industry
Dyess another is born and just as many
people looked up in awe as new Armstrong
took those first steps on the moon we're
about to take our own first step all
over again
[Applause]
[Music]
this time with renewed interest better
technology and a better vision for the
new space industry
new manufacturing possibilities in
microgravity the possibility of
colonizing the Moon and Mars taking a
vacation in space there currently
unknown but future spin-off technologies
that can come from this are all great
reasons for investing resources into
building this new industry what other
industries or enabling technologies will
we discover as we head into the unknown
space may be dark but in this instance
the future is bright
so what do you guys think do you think
that we'll have a brand new space
industry or are you completely skeptical
and think that this will all amount to
nothing if you do want more on space
check out my previous episode I'll leave
a link after this it covers the story of
the first man in space and also explains
why the Russians were so much better
than the Americans at everything space
related during the 1960's so I'm
finishing off I do get a lot of people
asking me how I do certain things like
editing or productivity if you do want
to make your 2020 a year of
self-improvement a great place to start
is by learning a new skill Skillshare
has you covered there's a great course
by Thomas Frank on productivity here
you'll learn how to build a custom
system to get ideas from your head into
motion I especially like the concept of
review days to stop all your tasks
running away from you for ColdFusion
viewers Skillshare is giving away 2
months of premium membership to help you
explore your creativity if you click the
link in the description box and after
this it's about $10 a month and with all
of that that wraps up the video this has
been - go go and you have been watching
ColdFusion thanks for watching and I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
cheers guys
are you thinking
[Music]